[Music]
[Music]
all the good men gone and where where's
a streetwise Hercules
you're looking particularly beautiful
tonight there a problem
good the identities of our serving
agents have been exposed the country is
in a state of complete chaos that the
universe sends me you sir yes alright
buff we're going on a mission not a
honeymoon destination
south of France sir I'm the missile
they're just like this so they're French
cyclist buff and they're obstructing Her
Majesty's Secret Service she's the key
to this case I'm not sure I've ever met
a man quite thank you let me clear up
the uncertainty here you haven't
virtual reality it's completely
immersive and some people do track their
actual surroundings I think we can
pretty much guarantee that's not going
to happen tell me the agent you've got
in the field is making some progress
target acquired
this is a job for the shoebox and no one
must have a slightest clue we're here
[Music]
till we meet again
that was sooner than I expected Oh
you
you